book from the illusionist darren brown
pushes people
to think differently to help overcome
anxiety how does that work
well let's find out from the man himself
hello to you john it's always great to
see
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning as i said the book
encouraging people to think differently
to overcome anxiety tell us how we do
that
uh well it's there are two big uh ideas
in the book one and it's a rewrite of
or a shorter version of a book called
happy that i wrote a few
a few years ago which is a big book it's
quite a commitment this is a smaller
version
two big thoughts one is a stoic
idea the book is largely about stoicism
which is
to only try and control the things that
you're in control of and this is a 2 000
year old recipe for minimizing
unnecessary disturbance and anxiety the
only things you're in control over your
thoughts and your actions
everything else what's going on in the
world what other people do what they
think of you and so on
these are things that are actually
outside of our control and it's
ridiculous to try and control them and
that's how you
you know largely make yourself
frustrated um so you kind of roll with
those things all those things on the
outside you decide just to kind of
uh roll with them and you bring your
center of gravity
uh inside by by separating those two
things
and that's a good recipe for a kind of
robustness and i think that works and
there's another thought which is sort of
the
opposite of that which is to let a
certain amount of anxiety
sit uh as you say we all kind of have
these moments in life all of us where we
are
anxious or what we feel that we've
failed and what life has the upper hand
um and we tend to feel very alone and
and it's actually bizarrely those times
when we're most connected to other
people because this is
it is the actual weight of life it's
when we're strangely
most connected with others and of course
the lockdown is a very literal example
of that here we are on the one hand
very isolated on the other hand sharing
in this
uh extraordinary thing and i think by
leaning
into that feeling of sharedness that can
really help too
but if you take on too much anxiety and
you don't have an outlet there's only
one way that that's going to go isn't
there so how do how do you
of course have to control your anxiety
but there has to be ways that you can
express it and is that turning to other
people for help
yeah i mean we may all feel that i mean
what plenty of people
feel that you know they can thrive in in
in lockdown and that it's
you know they have a relatively good
experience of it i mean that's that's
sort of
some people are definitely having that
while other people are having a terrible
time but i think irrespective of how
much
we think we can thrive on our own we
desperately do need
a connection with other people so as
much as i love the stoic idea of
of this very robust sense of self i
think at the same time as where we can
lean out lean out into a shared uh
experience and turn
sort of sometimes just to turn a feeling
of sadness into a sort of
melancholy uh understanding that this is
these things are
a part of life a part of the human
experience uh
that's important to suggesting
constantly that that importance of
of connection and reaching out and
finding shared experiences is
hugely important quite often in job
interviews they say where do you see
yourself in five years time
um you say be careful of long-term goals
yes i think goals are very good in the
short term uh but
really what i what i suppose this whole
book of my thinking is about is the
opposite
of that kind of goal setting believe in
yourself
super optimistic kind of american model
which bizarrely is based on calvinism it
inherited a protestant
work ethic uh where you can seemingly
make the universe provide just by
believing in yourself enough and the
problem is with that
is that it just doesn't work and then
when life has the upper hand and when
things go badly
you've got nothing to do other than just
to blame yourself and to add your own
add a feeling of failure to your list of
problems the reality is we have all our
aims and our goals on one side of the
graph
the other axis is stuff that life throws
back at you what they used to call
fortune
and we don't have much of a respect for
fortune anymore and we live an
x equals y diagonal line we kind of
meander along that line
uh and sometimes life has the upper hand
and sometimes we do so the key is i
think
not to believe that we can crank that
line up into line with our
aims and goals but to make our peace
with how fate and fortune
uh rolls out from day to day and to roll
with that to make up to live in an
easier accordance with fate
as the stoic said two thousand years ago
yeah that's easier to do darren as
one gets older from my own experience
but not so much when you're younger
no when you're younger it's uh there's a
thing i'm about to be 50 next year
extraordinarily and
there is a thing i think that happens
particularly as you get older that you
you look for the thing that is bigger
than you to serve that thing i think
that's an important part of the kind of
passage into the second half of life
you find meaning by throwing yourself
into something bigger than you
losing yourself in that thing that's not
really the project for the first half of
life but it is for the second
ambition and so on is it sits
uncomfortably with the second half of
life
so yeah there are there are definitely
changes in life i'm also naturally quite
introverted so i sit
comfortably with these things so you
know our general constitutional makeup
makes a big difference as well
but nonetheless i think these are
important ideas that just as part of the
human experience are worth bearing in in
mind
50 my goodness i'm 35 this time um an
illusionist
um how do you um how do you perform on
stage
if you are a natural introvert because a
lot of people
listening to you this morning would
think he can't be an introvert we've
seen him on the telly box
i know and there i am you know saying we
shouldn't try and control things outside
of our control and my job
is to you know control things that i
shouldn't have any control over
um i think that's just part of the
natural
thing that performers have i think it's
quite it's quite common to be quite
i'm not terribly shy but i definitely
have that
that sort of introverted thing and it's
very nice to go out and be this sort of
well-rehearsed charismatic version of
yourself
uh of an evening very happy with that
nice
it's good how are you coping with
lockdown you okay
it's good i'm painting i'm uh i've been
writing the book
and then uh i've been painting i paint
large
portraits which i'm now for the first
time actually uh
selling so i feel like a proper artist i
thought you made a tin of dulux and
doing the bathroom walls not that at all
no no no no paul have you got any
trades is there any there that we can
have a look at no maybe next time maybe
we can chat to you again next week and
you show us some of your work if you
don't mind
that would be lovely that would be a
real treat that's fantastic we'll do
that i'll make sure that somebody gives
you a call it's good to talk to you
thank you
thank you for having me on nice to speak
to you thank you
um it's great wasn't it let's see if we
can get him back on the table